[Music]
talk talk fast you first my name is
Sarah Connor
August 29 1997 supposed to be Judgment
Day
that I change the future
saved three billion lives
enough of a resume for you know
the future
you can change our fate
[Music]
protects you
never seen one like you before almost
human I am human
just enhanced
why do you care what happens to her
because I was her I can see you're very
upset I'm going to help you protect the
girl
because
if you don't make it
everybody dies expect a big pain brother
whole body's a weapon
all right
[Music]
and this is all over I am going to kill
you I understand
[Music]
I'll be back
now do we win by keeping your lives
Terminator dark state is the direct
sequel to Terminator 2 pick up the
characters that we knew from Terminator
2 and we carry them forward we get to
continue the story with Jim backed and
the writing in the producing chair
he knows the material nobody else
I think for fans of the franchise the
biggest thing is that Linda's returning
people love this character people love
Sarah being back is wonderful
Sarah's a force to be reckoned with and
I was ready to explore that delighted to
work again with the Hamilton direct with
Cameron Tamela played with all the new
cast
his new film is recaptured that tone of
those first two films its grid it's fast
its intense and it's just a
white-knuckle ride
[Music]
[Music]
two days ago I had this nice simple life
I know it's a nightmare
[Music]
stop
[Music]
[Applause]
who are you my name is Sarah Connor I
never seen one like you before
almost human I am human
why do you care what happens to her
because I was hurt
now do we win we win by keeping you
alive
[Music]
last night I was standing there looking
at a monitor on one camera with Linda
Hamilton and on another camera on
Schwarzenegger I thought holy [ __ ] I'm
making a Terminator movie then let's
recapture that tone
it's r-rated [ __ ] grin it's gritty it's
fast it's intense
work hard and play hard and this is what
this movie was all about Jane has his
fresh vision and like what he did in
Deadpool his action is it's just a fast
white knuckle ride you better watch your
ass I hunt terminators a metal
[ __ ]
but follows tonally in the footsteps so
t1 and t2 that adrenaline rush feeling
that sense of terror
the action is 10 times bigger it's like
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
relentless it just does not stop
just [ __ ] insect
[Music]